people don't need to take attendance
i'll just try to sleep
um
okay well why don't we go ahead and get
started um
welcome everyone to our
continued effort to
uh move our conference series to
in person
uh we have a small group here in big 124
but we are here
and um i see that we
have 26 others online
so that's great
we still
have not
solved our um
all of our audio problems
we will still
the speaker will still need to
um repeat the questions
because um
we don't have a way of
capturing
well speaking here in bit124
and i don't know how well the
audio will come across
okay so um
today is a
webex
i'm sorry today today is a um
doctoral symposium
sorry
um
and um
this as uh many of you know
especially those in the phd program that
this is um one of the steps along the
way um in the
uh to starting one's research that
culminates in the dissertation and then
the
awarding of the doctoral degree so in
the
um
symposium
the
presenter
talks
it kind of gives us a general overview
of the research area that they're
developing in and starting to develop a
possible dissertation topic
the
student will then
work towards
um finding
finding a
doctoral advisory committee
and um starting on their
research
and so um michael uh kolostekov is going
to uh present his symposium today
at some point in the not too distant
future he'll be back with his
um proposal defense where he will
defend his dissertation proposal
and then at some point further down the
road will
um
defend his proposal and if successful
but will be awarded a phd and will get
to march in uh graduation just like some
of you will be able to march this coming
june i will remind everyone again that
um everyone is welcome to attend
graduation both those who are graduating
and and others i intend to be there um
and that weekend is also our um
department banquet that we have each
year in non-pandemic times
where um everyone including a guest is
invited and you already have a save the
day that's the saturday
before graduation and um
um
lynn is working on a venue and
hopefully many of you will be able to
thank you
okay so let me uh let me introduce
michael who many of you know since he's
been in the program for a while
um
before studying informatics his
background is mostly in nursing
he um obtained a bachelor of science in
nursing and a master of science in
nursing from san jose state university
specializing as a family nurse
practitioner
he then also received postmasters
training
in
adult gerontology
and um
when he's not
pursuing his studies he actually um
works part-time
um as a nurse
at
sciences diamonds a nurse practitioner
adherence okay full time as a nurse
practitioner here and it turns out that
it's part of my um
background so
i will turn it over to him uh he will
give us his presentation there'll
hopefully be time for a question and
answer and and again we're gonna have to
kind of muddle through the audio
issues until we
get them fully solved so go ahead thank
you
hi michael before you get started
there's a little bit of vibration in the
audio so i don't know
if it's
maybe we're too close to the microphone
or
so but i just thought i'd let you know
right now is it better now because i
probably was a little bit too close to
the mic then
it's still i'm still hearing the static
static
yeah
i i mean the the sound is great here
um are others um
here in static others out there in web
excellent
yeah i'm hypocratic
yeah
it's only when you speak
[Music]
okay
is that any better
yes yes great better
yes
i see one yes
okay better okay yeah his cell phone was
right next to this sorry whatever this
thing is here with the two eyes this
piece is so sensitive
okay
hi my name is mike kolesnika and i'm
going to talk about his ability of using
machine learning
to predict optimal amount of blood
transfusion in trauma patients
and uh i have a little bit of mixed
audience today so hopefully maybe
something you know if you want to close
that participant's window
so i have a little bit of mixed audience
today so there might be some people from
uh my work joining in as well so i will
try to cover some basic uh things as
well um so they kind of
some medical things for the
uh machine learning people and some
machining people for the clinical people
all right um
the history of blood transfusion can be
divided into three distinct periods
first is the romantic period and the
common theme for this period was
blood has supernatural properties and we
can hear some echoes of it even now but
it started all this european display in
medea where replacing old man's blood
would give full rejuvenation to the
person
and that notion you might hear uh even
in modern fall songs and uh folk stories
in shakespeare's king of lyre which was
uh even
more recent uh blood uh creates some
special bonds between uh relatives
suspicion and
uh king of the
refers to the blood uh blood bond uh
and being betrayed by his own blood and
breath
uh in nazi propaganda even in the 20th
century the blood was seen as a sign of
um
intelligence or degeneracy and uh
specifically uh some special blood types
they hijacked some um research of
prominent scientists and they were
trying to use this for a rigid theory
propaganda
more recently even dieting is related to
the blood there are uh in the um
dieting by blood type
there are beliefs people would uh coming
from agrarian or fisherman's or hunter
society they have different type of
blood and that actually creates the
episodes in our society
so um
in more
recent there is a period of early
experiments this blood and the common
theme of that would be high mortality
and questionable benefits
so it started in 1667
uh when uh blood was used in two places
simultaneously and they are not related
believe not to be related but the
experiments eerily
uh similar the blood was transfused from
an animal from ship to two mental uh
mentally ill individuals both of them
died
and after that uh the blood transfusion
was banned for a while and that's the
medicine started to experiment this
blood transfusion again in the 19th
century
and
it was given uh for treatment uh
conditions such as pms
melancholy and delusional lunatics worth
mental health uh and sometimes even for
tuberculosis cancer and chronic anime
which
for which the blood transfusion could
actually be beneficial
modern time begins in 1901 there's the
discovery of the four different blood
types by
card lonsteiner
and it was continued uh similar the same
discovery was done in 1904 by ludwig
herzfeld he also discovered that for
different blood types but he also
contributed by creating a blood
acceptance chart
uh as you know there are four different
types of blood
uh and all negative blood can be
transfused to anybody
however there are only six percent of
people who have o negative blood
so that
it's a sparse uh
commodity
uh in the modern uh science also
starting in the world war one there was
a link between how much of blood person
can lose before onset of shock
and that was believed to be 40 of blood
if the person if the
souls are injured in a battlefield loses
about 40 percent of blood they
begin to go into the shock
and trauma is still the leading cause of
death and hemorrhagic shock is accounts
for over 80 percent of deaths in the
operating room and over half of the
deaths in the first 24 hour period
so that's why i believe um dealing with
the blood would be beneficial for our
patients however blood transfusion is a
medical treatment and like any medical
treatment it has pros and cons so there
are transfusional reactions when you
give too much blood uh not too much
blood but when you give um
blood uh to a patient they might get uh
corticaria which is just an itch
uh they can get a little bit of fever
uh
and there are
those are mostly benign conditions but
taco is transfusion acquired
cardiovascular system overload that's a
serious complication
next one is transfusion related acute
lung injury that's also a very serious
complication
sepsis and phylactic shock and hemolytic
reaction those are very serious
complications as well
the rate you are seeing here is uh per
100 000 units transused the more blood
we transfuse to a patient the more
chances they get to get a
reaction to the blood transfusion
uh there are also delayed types like uh
draft versus host digits which is very
rare
and uh
there is another uh very uh
scary complication of blood consuming
when i was in school it was used called
uh
the little triad now it's a little
diamond
so um
when person loses blood their body
temperature goes down it's sign of the
shock
when the
temperature goes down it's called
hypothermia
hypothermia causes acidosis and it
causes cardiology acidosis when your
blood becomes acidic and cardiopathy is
the result when your body temperature is
low and your
blood ph is getting low acidic
you get more blood more bleeding
when you give person a blood
that blood often contains
anticoagulation and medication so it
prevents it from being clotted in the
back
uh and it also
uh when you bleed you lose calcium
so
um giving more blood to the person who
doesn't need it kind of creates a spiral
you get more acidic you get more
hypothermic you lose more blood you get
more carbohydrate and again
so this is another reason why i want to
make sure
we get enough blood to the patient to
resuscitate but not too much so i think
my research will help to uh in the
clinical utility it will help to reduce
complications of unnecessary blood
transfusion as well as reducing wasteful
practices again blood is rare and
improves survivability of the patients
currently we predict massive blood
transfusions by few different methods
there are simple and there are complex
methods of predicting blood transition
the simple methods is shock index abc
method and larson scores what they have
in common is
uh sensitivity is kind of low
specificity is high
but uh they uh the shock index is a
relationship between heart rate and
blood pressure
and uh
abc method also looks at the mechanism
of injury and fast results fast is a
focused abdominal ultrasound that's
looking for the blood or
free liquid in in the stomach so once
you determine this patient is bleeding
in the stomach
you most likely will need blood
transfusion
and larson score is very similar to that
those
methods are simple they are easy to
carry out in case of emergency but they
are not very sensitive
now what about complex methods of blood
confusion
determining the muscle blood transfusion
there are few of them and i put out the
most popular ones
most of them they are a chart which
assigns you a score
so it's a scale so a score is being
assigned for a heart rate above a
certain point blood pressure below a
certain point
some presence and absence of
bone injuries
they are
they are not very sensitive
they are very specific
but if you compare the two pictures on
top and on the bottom the on top picture
that's the trauma team waiting for the
trauma victim coming in on the bottom
that's actually all hell brought broke
loose because you don't have time to
carry out complicated mathematical
formula in that situation
so my sense
the complicated
uh complex prediction methods were not
used
currently in practice
however the uh
storage for a good uh pre-hospital
scoring system prediction method is
still on this is a recent article last
year public publication and again we are
looking at the
mechanism of injury
gunshot wound versus uh motor mechanical
collision uh certain level of heart rate
and certain level of uh systolic blood
pressure
uh we assign the square and this is how
we predict new to the massive blood
transfusion all in all when i looked at
different predicting and prediction
methods i found about 30 variables which
are used
more or less
some of them related to the vital signs
some of them related to patient
characteristics and some are love values
special
um diagnostical studies and medications
because medications can be blood
thinners patient patient blood thinners
and even a small injury might require
blood transfusion and also patients
might have medications like beta
blockers which mask the symptoms of
shock uh a patient is gonna
beta blocker their heart rate might be
72 all the way until they go into
serious complications from the blood
loss
i
was lucky enough to get some preliminary
data
from trauma
system
and i did some uh graphs
and uh what i noticed is in uh in our
graphs they uh there are some
um
some variables which are very valuable
to determine people who need the blood
transfusion and as you can see the
systolic blood pressure as it goes below
100
it requires
uh it's strongly correlated with the
amount of blood transfused to the
patient
glasgow comma scale it's another
indicator we are looking
um
glasgow comma scale assesses your
ability to walk talk and act so normal
person like
anybody sitting here will be about 15
me because i'm a little bit under the
stress will be about 14. this chair will
be about three
three is the lowest you can get
so as you can see the lowest below four
was three and that's the highest amount
of blood needed for the transfusion
so this chair will need to have a lot to
be saved
um so my research question is
feasibility so is it possible or is it
not possible to use machine learning to
predict the amount of blood transfusion
and trauma victims
and i'm planning to use sequential
linear mixed methodology method
study
um i have couple of specific aims aim
number one what i would like to do is i
would like to explore the information
used to decide who needs a blood
transfusion and how much blood
transfusion to be trans used
uh what i wanted to do is i wanted to go
to the
trauma surgeons to people specifically
who do
uh who make the decision to transition
or not to tensions and they want i want
to figure out what triggers their blood
transfusion how soon they make this
decision and what triggers to
discontinue blood transfusion
um
my specific aim number two i would like
to use machine learning methods to
um
to analyze the data
and to
build a couple of predictive analytics
so things like
uh artificial neural network rnn
and uh i would like to evaluate there
are possible predictive
properties of different models
what do i mean by that um
i had a patient a few um
a few weeks ago
who dropped the blood pressure
patient on the floor gunshot wound to
the leg dropped blood pressure had a
little bit of fever got a little bit
confused
um he was in a hospital for a while he
was not bleeding my first thought would
be maybe he is getting a little bit
septic
and i was thinking
if if i can say and this patient is
getting accepted the computer probably
can tell me the same thing but i don't
know how valuable this information would
be what do i need to know at this point
i wanted to know his blood pressure in
two hours
so maybe getting the prediction uh
the diagnosis as the as the outcome will
not be as valuable for the clinicians as
certain uh clinical characteristics in
the
future uh and this is my aim now of
three i would like to go and talk to the
uh
clinical surgeons once i get the models
built and once i see what they can
produce i would like to go back to the
surgeons and find out
how valuable the data i can produce for
them
um
[Music]
so as far as the qualitative uh it's a
big part of my research and uh for the
people who are not very familiar with
this qualitative i'll just go over a
quick overview
i'm planning to do propulsive sampling
the reason for that is this is a very
small group of people who does this
decision they have a special knowledge
they have uh the insight and that's what
i want to get from them
i'm planning to do semi-structured
interviews so basically i'm asking
open-ended questions and i'm looking for
the answers in the narrative not simple
yes or no it's not simple liquid scale
and then i'm planning to to use
triangulation to establish validity of
the answers so hopefully the data coming
through different methods of
research like
questionnaire observation and interviews
will give me
similar results and that will uh
establish the validity of the data and
i'm planning to use saturation to
discontinue
my uh interviews and the qualitative
method uh studying the first phase
once
i know new themes are detected
uh as i mentioned i've been lucky to get
some data from trauma team and this is
an imbalanced data set so most of the
patients who come through
um
through the emergency room as the trauma
victims they don't need
um they don't need that blood
transfusion only a small portion of them
so um
this is a data set of about almost 600
people and less than a hundred of them
needed a blood concern i think it's
number is 87
uh and again when you are looking at the
units of blood transused it looks more
like survival data
because most of the people get about two
uni one to two units
and there is only one person who needed
37 units of blood to be transused
so
that creates a little bit of difficult
uh
time for the machine learning to get the
hang of this data
there are different approaches you can
use to the data to the imbalance
database
um you can increase the sample you can
kind of balance it out
uh decrease the number of variables
and in my preliminary evaluation i found
out
some data is not that useful like
patient height and weight did not
correlate the amount of blood needed for
the transfusion
um
and
we can also use we need to use specific
metrics for this uh system sensitivity
specificity uh precision rate and
receiver operating uh
characteristic curve which has been used
in many uh machine learning articles
uh and that one basically shows what's
the area under the curve so when you
look at the true positives and false
positives if you are trying to get as
many true positives and as little of
false positive identified by the by your
model
uh the perfect skill classifier will be
upper left corner that's when you get
close to 100
uh the no skill classifier will be the
diagonal line so it's 50 50. you flip
the coin and you get as good results as
your model and uh
then you get better than no skill and
worse than no skill in my preliminary
attempt i got 0.64 which is a little bit
better than no skill
but um i hope to get
better than that
uh machine learning based prediction of
transfusion has been uh has got a little
bit of attention uh lately and this is
one of the researches i found uh
last year
so this article basically they did they
were known specific to trauma but they
used uh sensitivity uh they they used uh
neural network
they used uh
logarithmic regression
uh logistic regression uh they used
random forest and they used graduate
boost and they got quite
nice results
um
so this is um
the prediction of
a massive blood transfusion was more
difficult for them because it's more
difficult task
so they got low recall rate but still
very uh fairly good
rock
data
the in the critics for this research
what i'm trying to say is this is a
little bit more
simple task than i'm trying to do when
you have under controlled environment
your patient coming for the routine
surgery you know in advance their uh
level of hemoglobin and hematocrit
you know
the kind of procedure they are getting
you know how much expected blood loss
and then you can make a very simple
decision how much to transducer or not
to transfuse this patient
uh i've done it when i was working in a
collaborative medicine clinic
this i mean you have to do some
calculations but it's fairly simple
um
it gets more
dicey when you are getting a patient
coming in an ambulance
uh and you don't know past medical
history you don't know what kind of
surgery they will need
all you have is just some uh
preliminary data
imbalance data set has also some
advantages there are certain uh type of
machine learning tools we can use to
identify outliers
uh one of them was
self-organizing pubs and the other one
is
variational out encoders
variational encoders is a generative
model
what it does is um
you get data kind of constrict
constricted from the input all the way
to the bottleneck that's how your system
learns the distribution and when it
generates the data back it tells you if
your uh
patient belongs to the distribution of
resident or it belongs to a different
distribution
it's used to determine
fraud on the credit cards and it's also
used in the cell phones
to clean up the
output
uh once again in my preliminary report
i've used uh
uh
variational out encoder and it did show
one outlier
and i believe that outlier was the
person who had
37 units of blatants used uh on a
self-organizing map it works a little
bit more like on propensity score
so it kind of it clusters the data based
on all the parameters you give together
and it looks for the outliers on this
draft on the left side you can see the
darker the score uh the darker the
quarter uh
it's more cl packed close close together
and the lighter the color uh that's the
outliers
um red circle
says the first needed
massive blood confusion
uh and uh the square says it's not so as
you can see there are some dark squares
who needed blood transfusion
and there are some light squares who
didn't
so i don't know if it's going to work
um
another interesting research i have seen
was um
developmental field artificial
intelligence triage tool
that they were trying to use artificial
neural network and one of the data
points was location of the gunshot
injury on the trunk
looking at that the machine was able to
predict if the patient is going to die
if the patient needs blood constitution
and the patient is going into the shock
when i thought about it i thought well
injury location is definitely makes a
difference
uh the type of the uh injury pattern uh
can determine if the patient is going to
die if the patient will need a blood
transfusion and um if the patient needs
um
more attention then some patients will
need more attention than others and i
was thinking what can we do in the
hospital when the patient is admitted to
the immersion syndrome and most of the
patients they do go through the chest
x-ray they don't get some abdominal
x-rays and they do get cat scans so if
the presentation of the trauma pattern
important for the determining of the
blood transfusion you might be able to
use
cnn
convolutional neural network
and that might help us to do
classification later on to figure out if
this patient
certain
outcomes can be predicted based on the
uh x-rays which are not related directly
to the number of ribs broken or uh
presence or absence of a pneumothorax
another idea i had was uh
uh
lately uh there were uh some use of um
recurrent neural networks and typically
it's used in a few
in few different things it's a time
series so a most simple example i i
could think of would be prediction of
the cost of the
stock
on the stock market
what you see on this picture is machine
is learning
how the stock market behaves
and
the blue one is the actual stock market
the green one and the green line shows
the machine learning how the stock
market will
predict and the red one that's actually
making the predictions
as you can see it's not exact but it
shows the pattern quite often the
pattern is what we need to see in the
clinical picture
in medicine it has been used to predict
people who are going to develop um
septic shock
and
blood sugar in the blood sugar it's
actually used for artificial pancreas it
gives bowls of
insulin based on the
predicted value of blood sugar in the
next hour or two
there is also a possibility of using
clean force
reinforcement learning i don't know if
it's going to work it's a far-fetched
so um it's uh
what's the reinforced learning uh in
simple terms uh it's
ability to uh
ability of uh machine to learn how to
navigate in the in the uh decision
domain
so um
it gets rewarded for making right
decision
it gets punishment for making wrong
decision
now what's the decision damian if we can
just define every patient's state by the
variables such as blood pressure heart
rate and other important variables which
i will determine in the first
phase then we can see if um
if the machine can be told how which
action is the best to be taken under
these
circumstances
this is how the
tesla self-driving car works
um
it's
a lot challenging i don't know if i'll
get there
and as far as the days i'm planning to
get most of my data from uh trauma um
travel program here at
uh the interesting question would be if
i can get ambulance data
because there are some vital signs
statement in the ambulance at some
intervals of time and that actually the
time series i'm hoping to use for the
rnn training
um
how will my approach be different well
on first hand i'm going to
see what what what is important to make
the decision of the blood transfusion
and then i will do the statistical
correlation and then i will see what
models will work and
hopefully
i can make some tool
as far as the timeline all in all i'm
planning to get it listening here
[Music]
but i don't know
um
on paper it always looks good
so all in all this is a feasibility of
using uh machine learning to predict
optimal amount of blood transfusion and
a trauma victim
uh i'm going to do it in three separate
steps
explore the information
needed build a few machine learning
tools
and find out the usefulness of the tools
they've built
i'm ready for the questions
sure can we go back to the slide where
you talk about your observations and and
make sure you repeat the questions so
the folks on webex can hear so going
back to this uh slide where i had some
observations which ones
there was a slide where you said i in my
observations
this one
it's it's pretty it's pretty toward the
end
yeah semi-structured interviews
back there
yeah in my previous
yeah okay
my previous observations it wasn't it
was yeah that was this one okay
yeah i wanted to know a little bit about
how what what do you know about the
context that this will be used in um
especially if things are like are rushed
then like complex tools according to
these cigarette big events or this had
to be thrown out
um
so
in you know in your giga rinser's view
one should use like really simple
decision trees and stuff that could be
like done with paper and pencil um but
if if something more complex is needed
then how is it going to sort of fit into
the
the
the ever-changing you know like
so how is it going to change in a random
stochastic environment of the emergence
alone right okay how does that sort of
you know what kind of context
okay so the context uh i'm not planning
to build the actual tool yet
i'm just planning to see uh what
information can be used
and um
to the clinicians i mean
i'm my goal is to determine how much
your blood needs to be transfused in the
first 24 hours
you get the first hour uh
in the emergency room which is really
chaotic
the decision in my opinion is made um
it's either there or not
so it's it's uh it's made by a
clinician's experience and uh
um
there might be some uh other hard data
used but
my guess was it's it's like clinching
experiences it is the number one tool
um
[Music]
i'm hoping uh
to see
if i'll be
i'll be lucky enough to train the
recurrent neural network to predict the
blood pressure
of this patient from admission in the
next hour
that might help this decision
uh to be made
so
that's a real question
i think so it sounds like there's enough
time
it's a 24-hour timeline yes 24 hours the
timeline for the uh actual uh prediction
uh but uh the first the first two hours
and the most chaotic and the most
important in the survivability of the
patient uh so it's like the golden hour
uh if we can
get the prediction from the ambulance if
i can if i can get this data and if i
can build the uh prediction for the next
two hours that that will be a big one
there were some questions in the chat in
the chat
you go to the top
power
rubber
um
fascinating topic study uh very timely
do you have any
uh thought on
to quantify use of agents such as
tranexamic assets to increase
development of dog reversal agents in
your work
would be interesting
transfusion requirements which might be
anticipated
very interesting to see
however
okay
um
that's a good question yes
uh trinidad seminar asset is used as a
conservant for the blood and it has
anticoagulant properties
[Music]
this might be one of the things one of
the variables i i i will need to use
to determine the outcome of the blood
transfusion and the amount of blood
needed for the transfusion
so um
this time i don't know yet
but i definitely i i want to take a look
at the use of anti-coagulation in the
patients and in the actual blood
blood supply where it's coming from
good question
questions here
i guess um i can um
um
i'm trying to what is the or i know this
is your symposium so you don't
necessarily have to have all the answers
but what what is the
clinical impact that you're aiming to
have but i mean one of the
one of the
issues i have with a lot of machine
learning is that they're predicting you
know they have a good data set yeah
we're predicting things that we may not
be able to do anything about or
um
are oh that's interesting and and
sometimes that can be valuable um but is
there a kind of clinical scenario you're
hoping
to um
address yes
that your whatever tool you develop
would result in some
improvement in patient outcomes in some
way yes yes
uh there are and i don't know
so what's the clinical uh benefit of the
study basically
uh what i'm trying to pursue
uh
i would like to make sure two things
happen number one if we can
identify patients who need a massive
blood transfusion earlier
that can uh help us to save live
lives uh the reason for that is blood
stored in a frozen condition so we have
it which is you have a blood bank and
all the blood is frozen there
we usually have about one box or two
boxes available for emergencies on any
given day
uh but when the patient is coming and
they need like 37 units of blood
transfusion uh we have to make sure the
blood has to be thrown in a very
controlled environment very slow you
cannot cook the blood
um
and uh my hope is being
communicating this data to the um
blood bank early enough so they can get
the blood start start to get it ready
and uh they will know how much you
volatile so
safely without wasting too much
for more questions
okay
one of the difficulties to be determined
uh the gold standard are you assuming
that doctors made the right decision to
confuse or not to transience doctors
sometimes did a vm of those animals do
you have account
for the fuzziness of the correct answer
i
this is this is a very good question so
yes uh i don't know
if uh the amount of blood that's used
recorded in the
electronic medical record
today is uh
the right amount of blood
um
needed for the patient uh it's a station
i mean if the amount of blood given to
the patient
was
necessary
and
enough
uh
this is one of the things i might have
to uh create a special uh
like conference or a discussion topic uh
looking at some cases to determine what
the clinicians think about it
um
at this point i don't think uh i can
i can get a reliable uh amount of
blood
i i i don't think i can get enough uh
reliable data to uh say um
this was this was appropriate this was
necessary
um
and then there's another question there
but but just uh um
you you may be able to get access um you
know to our data here we you know if you
have an appropriate project and get irb
approval you may well be able to get
access to
um you know data that is in our research
data warehouse that that could give you
you know potentially a much
larger data set i i you know we'd have
to see here
you know where you would find how much
transfuse i don't know if steve
that's a
you know how trans people get documented
yeah i don't know whether they but they
may well keep track of unassurance
specifically which you like which
specifically yeah yeah
yes we
do have we do have trauma industry and
we keep track of that my
my best guess would be uh if i can get
few experts to sit down and go i mean
it's not too many cases of blood
transfusion it's like 87 uh in uh uh 600
so
you might you might be able just to go
through a few of them and figure out if
this was enough or not if this was too
much or not
and just in addition to that
for individuals who do not receive blood
transfusion and then
have the negative outcome potentially
review those as well to see
you know do the experts thank you
yes that's a very good point uh to see
those people who did not get blood
consuming had a negative outcome to
review those cases too thank you
yeah and then i i also wonder you know
you may have
uh
kind of a large number of patients who
receive more than more blood than they
necessarily needed but also did not have
an adverse outcome and how would you
um
kind of distinguish that from
patients who had
just the right amount of blood
transfused
uh so how would i determine those who
received too much blood unnecessarily
but did not have a negative outcome
good question
short answer i don't know
yeah to be honest i don't know
yeah uh yeah truly that doesn't happen
too often uh uh that's transfusion
related acute lung injury and taco does
not happen too often
um
i i think i'll i'll try to leave you as
many blood transfusion cases as the
experts as possible to see um
at least to find the common themes
thank you
okay uh
[Music]
chris david has a question
the outcome
it sounded um you have a lot of
variables
something like a future selection to see
which ones are
cut off or thresholded
which is good condition versus sad
um
i don't know how easy
um
good point
i saw you had like
another question about your data
um so i'm on the bioinformatics side so
go go and ask
[Music]
yes the data source uh where the data is
coming from uh
right now i have data coming from the
registry
and uh trauma trauma system has a
special registry so they put uh
most of them what is believed to be
important data today uh into the special
database system
so uh when i look at it i have some
vital signs i have diagnosis
uh i have uh amount of buttons used
whether the patient survived or not i
mean uh it's extensive you can find lots
of data there what i'm uh and this is
the data i have used for my preliminary
search
what i'm planning to get is access to
the actual
uh epic database
and dig in there and uh look through
that i mean
the
the only way to get a good reliable data
is manually go through the records and
review them
and i know it's not the cheaper position
but you know
i have at least a year
so um
linda made a comment about four
comments up and then he okay also let me
see um
the rdw does have transcription
information not singular
at least not to be all up instead but
just want to make a comment what uh
challenging
overthink as well yes thank you they are
overheating with a big issue
certain models uh the other challenge is
that you're able to system different
circumstance practices even among
combinations
i have seen easy doctors to do it
differently my practice has changed to
go
[Music]
it also hard to give
consistent uh physiological reasoning
behind constitutional decisions
yes
thank you very good comment
uh our gni you can abstract cases and
have a number of experts decide whether
or not to trans check their agreement
rate and compare your system to them
thank you this is very good yes i have
seen something similar done in one of
the research articles on the
eye diseases uh that was the use of rnn
to determine um
i think glaucoma
um
yes and that that was a panel uh who was
classifying cases and making the
diagnosis think if that um cnn will do
better
thank you
uh and from genga last year in
sccm
i saw company came up with the software
from which you can get
real-time advice for massive transition
protocol not sure they use er or not
uh you know i have not seen that one
specifically
but i'll be very interested to take a
look at it
thank you
okay
more questions
why are we
yes
um gave some reasons earlier why on too
much blood is back
yes could you use those symptoms and i
assume there's like official adverse
event ratings but often isn't there
symptoms that maybe don't rate an
adverse event but make everybody on the
floor go oh boy you know we need to
watch this could you pull those data
points out and use it to assess
if somebody had to you know too much
blood too much blood but maybe not an
adverse event okay so is it too much
blood if they don't have an adversary
i mean if they're okay i mean maybe
wasteful but
but is it medically bad okay that's a
good question two questions number one
is is it medically bad to give too much
blood
and the second question is whether or
not i can uh find the data's
data points which determine if the
patient had too much blood okay
uh first of all let me ask answer the
third question is it too bad to give
unnecessary blood yes
you talked about that but if nothing
goes wrong if nothing goes it goes wrong
yes um
too much blood
yes
let me explain let me explain
um physiologically our body can lose
certain amount of blood and it can
destroy it
when we give unnecessary blood to the
patient
uh
by the mechanism we don't
exactly understand yet
uh it suppresses the blood uh the blood
production the bone marrow and it has
some uh autoimmune
uh response
so um
even nothing even if nothing but has
happened uh it's still not good
and it also uh one in twelve patients
will develop uh
antibiotics to uh to the blood given and
antibiotics i did not cover it in my
presentation because it's a little bit
too specific but
it's a big thing
next time the blood transfusion
you have to give to this patient might
get bigger complications and you have to
determine if the patient has uh
antibodies and it takes a very long time
to determine which antibodies they have
so in case of emergency it's a big deal
uh and in case of uh plant surgery it
gets things more complicated and then
the blood also has to be liquidly used
you wash out the leukocytes the white
blood cells from the red blood cells to
reduce the amount of complications for
those people it's more expensive
and the second part of your question is
whether or not i can find the data
points which can identify it
i don't know
i might i might not i think that
you don't know what the data points are
or you don't know you can get them i
don't know what the data points are i
think i will need to go to uh
talk to uh surgical
specialists and
intensivists to find out what they think
about it
thank you
for confusing
yeah
sometimes it's not documented
yep
okay a couple more questions here what
did i have uh
year yeah we've got that and
nina
it seems you need a good adverse
event classifier to determine your cases
and controls uh i assume when you say
even if nothing has happened to me
event
there was no sincere outcome
in my other events become
uh us cases right yes miley you are
right uh yeah wilder events uh and even
future events uh from the blood
transfusion like developing of the um
antibodies will count and not
necessarily we will know about it upon
the first transfusion
okay
next
okay well
i don't hear anymore i actually want to
ask um
can you hear me
yes i can hear you oh this thing
whatever this thing here is
maybe not um yes i can hear you or
actually can anyone hear me anyone out
there in webex land yes we can hear you
is that art yes
we can hear you think so well maybe not
yeah what's that
oh you can't okay yes
maybe take a minute
testing
so
um
i can see that i can hear me now
yes
i see a picture yeah i see lynn is that
karen's on
karen's thumbs up okay let me stop
sharing yeah maybe stop sharing yeah
okay
how about if i go back here can you hear
me okay yes i can hear you
plus minus fish knew i see your face can
you hear me
okay well axing whenever this thing is
here i see a picture of me is there
where is that camera coming from
it's this one oh oh it's coming from
this owl okay
yeah we can see this is um actually this
may help solve our problem
so um
okay well anyways um so i think we're
um almost at about time i want to um
thank michael for an interesting
presentation and i think we're all we'll
all look forward to see how this evolves
and um
we'll we'll adjourn for today and um
thanks thank you
okay well maybe this